So yesterday we talked about this New York
Times story that exposed that uh, Donald Trump's
tax returns
between 1985 and 1994, uh, show that Trump
lost more than one point $1 billion during
that 10 year period.
Paying no federal taxes in eight of those
10 years.
And the reactions from right wingers have
been varied and some of them were pretty interesting.
One approach from the right was, oh, don't
focus on the content of the report.
Don't focus on the substance of the New York
Times story.
Focus on the fact that the New York Times
got this information about Trump and that
they are bad, bad, bad for doing it and somebody
needs to be held accountable.
So here's one example of that reaction from
the right.
This is turning point USA flunky Charlie Kirk
tweeting sort of a perfect prototypical example
of concern trolling.
He tweeted quote, who leaked to the misleading
Trump tax information to the New York Times?
Why did they publish it?
Why didn't they report the leaker to authorities?
Section eight of the taxpayer bill of rights
says knowingly disclosing tax information
is punishable by prison.
Who is responsible for this hit job?
So that was one.
We know we see this all the time when it comes
to any reports based on leaked information.
If you like the leaked information, you focus
on the content and not how it was leaked.
If you don't like the content of the information,
you ignore the content and you focus only
on how did this information leak to begin
with.
Classic strategy employed more by the right
than the left.
But the left also sometimes we'll employ that
strategy.
A totally different approach was the approach
taken by Fox and friends, which is to argue
that this New York Times report proves how
fantastic a business person Donald Trump is.
But uh, they did it in this very strange word,
salad sort of format.
Here's Brian Kilmeade with his take and again
it, I don't know if you want to call it word
confetti or word salad, just struggling to
use the English language to communicate anything
of meaning.
Take a look.
He's a bold businessman, which is chronicled
here.
There's nothing about this article that should
surprise anybody that got the Daily News in
New York Post throughout the last 10 years
to give details.
Here's an example.
Uh, he said pass through income.
So for example, there might be an incentive
to go buy that building to buy that casino
because I'll take a loss this year in order
on my tax returns.
Because I want to buy for a rainy day.
I have the resources because there was a time
that, uh, he was, uh, actually building his
empire, the information, information focus
year by year at a time of gathering loss.
He bought his partners out of Trump tower,
the Trump Plaza hotel and casino.
He bought an apartment building West Palm
beach for 43 million and business losses for
68.7 million for us, or at least for me, I
can't imagine having that much money, spending
that much money and being in debt for him.
It makes sense.
He's buying now building it up because he
had confidence.
He knows who the properties will be worth
more.
The properties began to build an 86 he bought
and he, excuse me, an 87 he spent 29 million
on a yacht.
The market crashed the next day, so no problem.
He held onto it.
He bought a shuttle operation.
It didn't do too well, but he held on to it.
But when he sell it, he takes the loss on
his taxes.
So for you or I maybe buying a summer home
is a big move, or maybe even a trailer, but
for Donald Trump, he says, I got some money,
but I want to really expand my empire.
I want to take chances.
That's what he's done through his entire life
as a personality, as a host, as a businessman,
and guess what not all of us win on everything
we buy.
I think that's how the voter feels, absolutely.
So then in comes, another one of the genius
co hosts of Fox and friends, Ainslie Earhart,
and she actually calls all of this extremely
impressive.
She's impressed that Trump was able to lose
more than one point $1 billion.
It is an interesting look though at how New
York City real estate developers work in the
eighties and the nineties anything.
You read this and you're like, wow, it's pretty
impressive.
All the things that he's done in his life,
it's beyond most of us can ever, I don't know
that there's any suggestion that he broke
the law.
Yeah.
I think their suggestion is simply that he
used the tax laws to his benefit.
Yeah, that's the takeaway.
Steve Doocy and Ainsley Earhart, just so impressed
by Donald Trump in every way.
And unfortunately, I hate to say it because
I'm always newly depressed by the, um, lack
of limits, uh, to, to, uh, the ignorance that
people will fall for in this country.
A lot of people are falling for this, and
I want to clarify before we go any further.
Trump is a terrible president because his
policies policies are a disaster, right?
Trump's not a terrible president because he
lost money in the eighties and nineties.
Whether he made money or lost money in the
eighties and nineties, our analysis of his
policy today would be the same, right?
It's a disaster.
The reason that this actually matters is that
Trump's sole credential for even running for
president from the beginning is that he knows
how to run businesses that his businesses
are successful and that he would run the country
the way that he runs his businesses.
So that's why when people say, Oh, Trump losing
a billion, uh, was a strategy, we have to
pick it apart because it's actually the basis
for Trump being president.
That's so many of his followers actually cite
and lean on.
Now let's pick it apart.
It is true that sometimes wealthy people or
businesses will show or create losses on purpose
for strategic tax purposes.
It's also possible that Donald Trump did this
during some years for which we have not seen
his taxes.
The New York Times article that we've been
reporting on this week doesn't show that Trump
lost amounts of money that go way beyond what
would be logical with the idea that Donald
Trump is trying to deliberately limit the
amount of tax that he pays you in.
When you do that, you try to keep your losses
sort of in line with the gains that you're
trying to offset.
What Donald Trump lost in these years, in
most of those years between 1985 and 1994
goes way beyond what you would do as a strategy
to reduce or to try to zero out your tax liability.
There's no reason to go hundreds of millions
of dollars beyond the most advantageous amount
for reducing taxes other than you genuinely
and honestly lost money.
And unfortunately you've got people like Charlie
Kirk, uh, and the three clowns on Fox and
friends who are just good enough at changing
the narrative in part to how did this leak
and in part to Trump is really smart for doing
this.
And we should actually be impressed by him
that the narrative of Trump is good for the
country because he's good at business, continues
to spread and perpetuate itself like a virus,
which is quite frankly what it is.
We've got to pick it apart, not because Trump's
policy is good or bad based on whether he
lost money in 1987 but we've got to pick it
apart because this is his only credential.
This is the credential that his supporters
claim is the reason why he deserved to be
elected president.
And that one credential immediately crumbles
like a very poorly built structure.
Um, uh, as soon as you analyze it with even
the most minute a critical critical analysis,